we just through a lot of terms at you in
that last video so let's take a closer
look at common metrics and acronyms used
when it comes to advertising there are
five will be exploring CPC CPM eCPM CPI
and CTR knowing the definitions for each
of these terms is extremely important
especially as you're evaluating the
success of using ads in your product
let's start with CPC or cost per click
now this is essentially how much an
advertiser pays you if a visitor to your
site or a user of your product clicks on
their ad the acronym CPM is a little
tricky this stands for cost per thousand
and the M actually is the Roman numeral
for a thousand CPM is how much you earn
for every one thousand views of an ad
this can also be referred to as CPI or
cost per impression another item from
our list eCPM is then the estimated cost
per thousand views and is calculated by
dividing your total revenue by the total
number of views of the ad in thousands
eCPM is helpful when you're evaluating
the performance of different ads on your
site and you want to estimate how much
you'll make as the views increase lastly
we come to click-through rate or CTR
this metric measures how many users have
actually clicked on an ad it's
calculated by dividing the total number
of clicks by the total number of
impressions or views and multiplying
that number by 100 to get a percentage
so now that we've gone through each of
these definitions let's test your memory
and see if you can remember these
three-letter acronyms fill in the full
names for each of these acronyms using
the provided boxes